[Music]
and just when i thought gender reveals
couldn't get any worse
hey everybody think story here with our
final episode of raised by wolves a show
which has really surprised me i just
hope the writers know where they're
going we don't want another
moving on we have a lot to get to in
this video because i think we can all
agree this episode gave us more
questions than
answers so come with me as we journey to
the center of kepler-22b
try to answer some of the show's biggest
questions and what it could mean for
season two
but before we begin make sure to like
and subscribe as i'm hoping to have more
videos on the show in the future the
final episode of the season is called
the beginning a
title with several meanings first our
characters are thrust in
totally new beginnings champion leading
the children
marcus and the introduction of the
atheists and mother and father on the
opposite side of the world in the
tropical zone but the title is also a
play on the beginning of the bible and
the book of genesis where we get the
story of adam and eve in the garden of
eden
in eve's temptation by the serpent just
like how mother and father are thrust
into their own garden of sorts with a
serpent
at least the one in the bible didn't fly
or did it i've had it with these
[ __ ] snakes
on this [ __ ] planet our first
scene is with marcus who lucius kicked
the crap out of last episode when it was
discovered he was a secret atheist named
caleb he survived experiencing terrible
hallucinations telling saul that his
king has come
since midway through the season marcus
has been experiencing what he calls
the voice of saul he even tells sue that
he's the chosen one the one deemed the
prophet in the mithraic prophecy
like otho before him the voice of saul
has left him whoever controls this voice
and
will get into theories of who or what
that is later in the video
seems to ghost its subjects harder than
most girls do it to me on tinder once
he's done with them he casts
them aside and picks someone new in this
case he'll move on to paul but more on
that in a bit
father mother sue and the children are
looking for a safe place to have the
baby so naturally they choose one close
to a [ __ ] ton of creatures
we'll later find out that mother chose
this place because she quote
feels stronger here something about this
place resonates with the entity growing
within her and we also find out that the
voice has also been speaking to mother
listen to this before she gives birth
where is my baby
you said the voice has been talking to
her and if otho and marcus are any
indication
the voice will simply be using mother
and be done with her after it's gotten
what it wants
mother says that once the delivery of
her baby is complete they can make the
trek to the tropical zone it's kind of
an interesting remark since she
previously told tempest they shouldn't
go there until
she had her baby but with the mythrick
taken over the camp they may have no
choice
now i'll bring this up briefly but we
don't see any of the methraic this
episode either lucius or justina
will likely take over as leader however
with the introduction of the atheist
it's gonna throw off the balance of
power on the planet but marcus has a
secret weapon that could tip the scales
in his favor
but we'll get to that in the final scene
mother's belly has grown significantly
since
episode 9. sue says the cellular growth
is off the charts she seems to be going
over the regular nine-month gestation of
a human child in a matter of days
paul says not to worry this soul's baby
we're on a holy mission nothing can hurt
us i think they're really setting up
paul to be reunited with the mithrae and
after he finds out his mother isn't his
real mother even going so far as to
shoot her
he really can't go back to her he's left
to either go back to the mathrake or
search for his crazed father
in previous videos i theorized that the
voice could be the result of an ai
using the locator chips or android
hardware to communicate with whomever it
wants
but with paul's chip removed and also
champion hearing the voice who doesn't
have a chip in him the likelihood that
this voice's ai
is now extremely low on top of that the
voice knows about sue
and marcus's real identity even sue's
real name
mary eventually telling paul this it
seems to be
all knowing or at least able to dive
into the thoughts and memories of those
it takes control of
is it an actual god is it the planet
itself
and what is its connection to both the
dodecahedron temple and
alien creature whatever it is it seems
that this is the main mystery of raised
by wolves just like how lost was what is
the island
raised by wolves is what is the voice
campion asks mother if the baby will
have powers like
mother does in an interview with
newsweek creator aaron guzikowski
clarified that the serpent that comes
out a mother is
one of the same ilk as the serpent bones
they find all over the planet
however this particular serpent may take
on some of
mother's abilities so the fact we could
see it fly could mean that's one of
those abilities and that the larger
snakes
couldn't fly perhaps that's why they dug
those giant holes in the ground to
travel throughout the planet
rather than just fly all over the place
paul follows his mouse into a cave where
he discovers a bunch of paintings
and there's a lot to unpack here first
we have the lander
carrying mother and father and the
embryos but look at the direction it's
headed
it's not heading towards kepler it's
headed to earth or at least that's what
it looks like to me
in this shot here we can see a depiction
of earth and the other seven planets of
our solar system around it with the sun
near the bottom
if this is correct this circular drawing
over here might be kepler-22b
those swirls in its center denoting the
various underground snake tunnels it
also has three moons around it just like
kepler
does but what is really weird is the
human-like creature off to the side
almost as if it's some form of human
which is devolving and this idea of
devolution comes up later on in the
episode there's this hand here which
signifies whatever painted this was
human-like and i'm not
exactly sure what this red thing in the
middle is perhaps a representation of a
serpent
embryo the next thing we see is the
actual serpent and the weird thing here
is that it's moving we've seen these
kinds of moving images before back at
camp
could this be in paul's head is the
voice making him see this the thing i
find most interesting here
are mother and father's lander moving
toward earth or at least that's what it
looks like to me
suggesting perhaps that this is all a
cycle new life starts on a planet
civilization grows two sides destroy
each other and they must find a new
place to live
for the cycle to start anew campion
echoed this cycle of destruction in the
hibernation pod saying
no matter how hard you work to keep them
safe mother in the end
who will always destroy themselves over
and over and over again
father is still reeling from the fact
that mother is pregnant and learns the
truth about what happened
we communed in a virtual space and while
we did information was downloaded into
my drives
that's an interesting way of putting
flying vr sex she'll tell father this
being is their new mission that campion
and the rest of the gen ones were
only practice but as we'll find out
mother is being lied to this is
all an elaborate ploy by the voice to
have her give birth to the serpent
in one of the weirdest scenes of the
episode marcus hallucinates hunter
growing a snake out of his hand this
could be the voice making him see this
but given the hallucinatory blurring of
the image around marcus i'm inclined
this as being a delusion as this vision
tells marcus he still
saul's one true servant father displays
his dilemma using sticks and stones on
the one hand he wants to protect the
children
but doing so he'd have to be around
mother which angers him making his
ability to protect the children
difficult so in order to solve this
he'll later ask hunter to reprogram him
to lose all his memories
sue finds paul on the verge of throwing
out a pivotal piece of lander gear that
would make it
inoperable meaning they lose the ability
to travel to the tropical zone he tells
her that sol spoke to him and that
mother's baby
isn't safe there they need to stay where
they are we've seen the voices one hell
of a manipulator so having the serpent
in the tropical zone
likely means something may prevent the
voice from fully being able to take
control of it
my theory is that the serpent becomes
the physical manifestation of the voice
but in the tropical zone the voice won't
be able to control it because of the
strong electromagnetic field that
surrounds the area in episode one we
learned the methane
arc couldn't land there because of such
a field there's a tropical zone near the
equator
there's a considerable electromagnetic
field that's preventing us from landing
our arc there
mother goes to the pit wanting the
creator to help her understand what's
going on when she's attacked by an
alien creature now you may think this
thing is the same creature we saw
skulking around in previous episodes now
it may be
of the same species but the way it moved
and attacked seemed
so different than when it ran away in
its hideout compare this clip
to this
one has super speed and agility the
other is like me trying to rush the
bathroom after i've had chipotle now it
could also be that this creature has
devolved
rapidly during this time if a baby can
grow in a matter of days
can something devolve in a matter of
days too could the ark's crash landing
have shifted something maybe the
planet's electromagnetic field
hence when it crashed we started to see
the creatures who had never showed up in
the
12 plus years mother and father had been
on the planet regardless this thing
wants mother dead
perhaps because it knows it's carrying
the voices baby whatever the voice is
may have led to its people's death this
alien also holds a neanderthal skull
a variant of human species found on
earth but went extinct over 40 000 years
ago father analyzes it by
biting a piece of it gross and finds out
it's not from earth at all but native to
the planet
all of this is lining up the theory that
whatever lived on this planet before
may have taken off and landed on earth
to start anew or they made it to earth
retrieved some homo sapiens and
neanderthals and brought them back to
kepler-22b
either way it looks like things didn't
pan out too well as this thing has
according to father devolved father says
this planet has a history mother
a history i fear we are dangerously
ignorant of and i think much of season
two will explore
what the history of this planet is and
how things came to be
i'll mention it briefly but some have
said it looks like the engineer from
prometheus another ridley scott
production
but from the bit of research i've done
there just seems to be a lot of evidence
that disproves it
but that i might save for a different
video mother tells father she hears
something in the woods and for those of
you with a good ear you'll notice it's
the same exact song mother hums in the
lander at the beginning
take a listen and see if you can hear it
do you hear that
i think this is the voice feeding her
this song calling her to the secluded
cave where she'll eventually give birth
paul holds his mother or
not mother at gunpoint having heard her
real identity through the voice
he's so brainwashed by saul he'll end up
shooting the person who cared for him
over the last 12 years
really this woman has spent more time
with him than his actual mother
and one of the little facts we know
about the real sue is that she never
even spoke to her son paul ends up
running off and hunter follows him but
in the final shot hunter is back and
paul is nowhere to be found sue will
likely end up surviving she learned how
to be a doctor while in the hibernation
sim which may mean she'll get one of the
children to perform
surgery on her mother heads into a cave
where the dodecahedron alien from
episode 9 is found
on top of the device is shed serpentskin
similar to the kind father found near
the serpent bones in episode 1. this
alien thing wears a helmet
it's not an alien at all it's an android
or so it seems
notice the implant on the side of the
skull and the muscle fiber formations
that
kind of look like honeycombs it's almost
exactly like those found on mother when
campion was fixing her up
it seems that this android was locked up
in this dodecahedron by the shadow
figures
for the purpose of giving birth to one
of these serpents that's why we see it
spitting up white android fluid just
like mother did before she gave birth
the cylindrical shape of the helmet
allows for a sort of birthing canal so
mother gives birth to this absolutely
adorable serpent creature which latches
onto her for
sustenance she'll tell father that they
must destroy it as she fears once she's
been fed on this thing will want
blood she knows now that it wasn't the
creator who put this thing in her
it was something else they take it to be
destroyed down one of the holes but this
plan goes about as well as you'd expect
as it crashes into the core we get a few
flashbacks of her memories with the kids
reminding her what she's really there
for notice how their lander looks like
sperm hitting an egg like one of the
tarot cards and fitting since the title
of the episode is the beginning
marcus encounters a group of atheists
you can tell by the tattoos on their
faces who have
somehow made their way to kepler they
have a giant ship perhaps an
ark although in episode one the mithraic
said the atheists don't possess
one well looks like they do or at least
something that can transport a lot of
people
it might be a tarantula which was one of
the hidden easter eggs found on the
raised by wolves website if you haven't
seen how to access that check out my
episode 8 and 9 video he gets on the
comm link and tells the
the king of the world now marcus and
also the mithraic here look to be
severely underpowered but remember
marcus has mother's eye
the one that can turn her into a
necromancer and we've seen how just one
necromancer can bring down an entire arc
but just how exactly this will come into
play remains to be seen
mother and father miraculously emerge on
the opposite side of the planet on
pandora
nope it's the tropical zone they escape
from the lander their fate unknown
i think they'll be fine but it's the
giant really bad cgi serpent that
emerges from the lander having grown a
hundred times its size in a matter of
minutes that can't be good this leaves
all our main players starting in
totally new situations for the start of
season 2. we have the addition of the
serpent and the atheist which will
totally throw everything off kilter
and a murderous paul and marcus as wild
cards
i tried to highlight all the big events
in the final episode but if i missed
something
be sure to leave a comment below thanks
for watching and be sure to like and
subscribe so you'll know as soon as one
of my videos drops
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at think story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you